hi everyone it's jerry
let's have a look at a game from round
four
of the altbox norway chess tournament
2020.
on the wide end magnus carlson and he's
paired against fabiano caruana
so world number one versus two whenever
they're paired always interesting to see
how it plays out
whether decisive or drawn so
let's hop right in see how this one went
carlson
opens with namaste
he's been going with this greeting for a
few rounds now
uh there's a no handshake rule for this
tournament
so instead it's been for carlson at
least
in eyebow to you greeting
i'd say a good substitute for a
handshake
anyhow move one by carlson
d4 opening wise we have
nimzo indian defense queen c2 denotes
the classical variation white has no
interest in allowing doubled c
pawns white's prepared to recapture with
the queen we have this
on board an early imbalance
knight for bishop black playing in the
center
white activating the unopposed dark
square bishop pinning the knight
black gives up their strong central pawn
taking away from the center
if you're going to do this there ought
to be good justification
for it what is it
let's see b6
with b6 black's prepared
to deploy the queen bishop on an
atypical diagonal
a6 to f1 at the end of the day what does
this mean
it means for black that white will go
uncastled
black will eventually be capturing on f1
okay move 9 rook d1 is there anything
that grabs your attention
about this current position for me
it's the king side currently
well they've been spectators so far
all right this last move by white does
have its points
it discourages black from striking at
white's
strongest pawn c5
can be met with the capture and the rook
would be unleashed to the queen
all right sure enough the bishop on the
atypical diagonal
black questions the bishop while also
producing a flight square the pin is
maintained
fabi now offers a queen exchange
if white accepts the queen exchange
black conveniently recaptures secures f6
and is now prepared to strike with c5
next white doesn't want to help black in
that way
so ducks the queen exchange and now
hints at maybe damaging the king's side
while
also maintaining the queens on board
if you're going to have a damaged
kingside
in this case if black is going to have a
damaged kingside
yet you don't want to have the queens on
board
you don't want to have a drafty king and
the queen still be on
so black still pursues this queen
exchange queen c6
it's accepted at this moment you'll
notice it's accepted at a moment where
the knight is recapturing on c6 the
knight is not defended and the c
pawn is obstructed
now something i quickly uh
looked at is well suppose white tries to
be a pest
somehow uh and by pest i mean
maintain the queens with queen to b1
uh with the idea to you know maybe
damage the structure like this well
that's not working because
black is now with the queen not on d7
able to play knight d7 secure f6
connect rooks huge lead in development
for black
completely underdeveloped for white
black just moments away from striking at
white
center not a good idea at all
for white so queen exchange it is
we enter an ending bishop takes knight
grabbed my attention a little bit
because
it is not as if oh i damage your
kingside you have some weaknesses there
now
and i'm going to take advantage of them
i don't believe that that is the case
i believe it has more to do with i'm not
so
sure how effective my dark square bishop
will be in this
environment i think maybe this night
when given
if given a chance to move to
maybe d5 or e4 it can be a much more
effective piece than the dark square
bishop
an idea to put pressure on c7 i think is
something that would be
short-lived this this pawn is soon to
move
to c5 we're gonna have uh
the knights jumping around maybe on the
on the queen side c4 is a
very sensitive point in white's camp
okay in this game we do have bishop
takes knight
simplifying quite a bit two rooks apiece
a tricky knight for each
it's not fun you have to babysit b2
though for a little bit
c5 so this is where there can be some
structural changes
uh white in this position plays king to
e2
i questioned why not take here and say
aha i have
split your side pawns
uh the issue with this is that b2 will
soon be struck at
black will quickly coordinate with their
best piece
rook b8 you know if i'm to play out a
couple moves king e2 rook b8
what are we doing to defend b2 you move
the pawn you drop the a pawn
you move b you drop a white would have
to go for counter attacking moves
and we can have some variation like this
where
how to assess it completely equal
i actually prefer black though i feel
that
there is a better chance for maybe black
to coordinate
with their uh rook and knight than these
two
maybe somehow getting to e4 and b2
king is a little bit more exposed than
the black king
could see possibly coordination on f2
for the black pieces if we consider the
corresponding f7 square
not so clear how the the rook and knight
easily coordinate there
anyhow structural changes
capture on c5 yay or nay it's nay
at this point king e2
rook c8 rook c1 this is another moment
where there can be a structural change
black drops the knight back and now
that the knight has been driven back
white goes for
uh this breaking up of black's queen
side pawns
so there's not as much pressure in this
case over b2 on the b2
square so
this is another moment i questioned
because why did
fabi not capture on d4 i'm not sure
um i can't i can't quite put my
uh finger on this one um
maybe it's related to you know he did
not want to see the knight arrive
on this strong post on d4 it's a strong
post for sure
but at least the queen side structure is
rock solid for black
the knight can fall back the king can
improve to e7
and it's difficult for me
to see how either side makes substantial
progress
in this position
maybe an idea is something like this
anchoring a knight into c6
maybe that's something i'm not quite
sure
white is a tiny bit better having a
slightly better
night position and maybe
also because of this uh the king also
has a pretty good square on d3
again just sharing some thoughts i'm not
a hundred percent sure
these the kind of things i do when
trying to prepare
for this video so just some thoughts
there
at the end of the day black does not
want to see the knight on d4
um also i mean another another train of
thought is
okay yeah i know the pawns are split but
i'm still gonna have some counter
pressure on your queen side now that my
pawns are split so it's not just about
d4
denying the knight the d4 square but
yeah some play on the b
file will ensue okay as it stands right
now
white has a target now um the c5 pawn
so some pressure is directed there
it's a little it's
it's kind of interesting certain moves
right here for me
you'll notice as soon as that knight
went to d4 now
now this is where black thinks maybe a
bit more about playing c4
right as soon as as soon as
uh the knight is no longer a move away
from getting to that d4
square now black is like okay i'll go c4
now you can at least quickly get to that
d4 square but anyhow
another point behind c4 black doesn't
want to see that knight take up
maybe a strong post on the c4 square
all right maximum pressure on c4
three attackers two defenders if you
try to capture if you try to capture
away now
it's not a good time for that in the
game we have king to f3
what's the issue with capturing away on
c4 here let's find out
how would this work in the end there's
rook takes b2 check
this is a big deal because now the rook
has time to
drop back and defend this pawn should
should there be some pressure on it
if we look at a different position let's
say after king f3
if black let's say goes with f5
now we can capture away what's the
difference well rook
takes on b2 rook takes on b2 is not with
check
white is now on move and can continually
attack the pawn
not just in any way not along the file
because it could be defended but it can
continually attack the pawn along a rank
and the rook is never able to defend a6
rook c6
a5 rook c5 and eventually this guy is
one
this guy goes here and the pawn races up
to at least
a6 and white goes from there good luck
to black
trying to hold that
okay the difference between king on e2
and f3 was highlighted
a difference c3 in the game
black's giving away a pawn
yeah it's not considered best the c3
move there is a
an interesting defense rook to c5
which you know if white goes in for this
sequence now it's not entirely the same
because two rooks are still on board
and this rook has some nice lateral
movement it can continually harass the
king
with checks something like this and if
you try to
go here well you're going to the square
you you know you don't want to go there
rook takes b2 check
and if you block with the rook what's
happening there
chop chop rook takes b2 is now
threatening rook takes f2
and if you take with the pawn there's
rook takes b2 threatening rook b3 check
winning the a pawn so what am i getting
at
this little rook lift on move 25
is a nice resource i believe with these
uh
fifth ranked checks in mind
in this game we have c3
pawn is given away and after the game
carlson
uh said he was expecting caruana to
follow up
with knight to c4 trying to get the
knights off and play a rook specific
end game uh caron does not
uh go for that instead it's rook to c5
and now this pawn gets rolling a little
bit so the the white rooks now have some
air
some square to work with c3
the rook right now is block hater the
white king on f3
returns to assist in the defense of c4
and some regrouping here the last this
last move is paving the way for knight
to b3
trying to remove the defender so this
pawn can can run
the move played here was rook to c6
considered better
is king e7 kind of that's a tough move
to play undoing
undoing uh undoing your
your earlier king move i believe this is
to keep up in the option of rook to d8
threatening to move the knight
with the discovery uh in this game a
preemptive move
rooked his c6 i guess anticipating
knight to d3 maybe even rook to b3
the rook getting harassed so
after this move we have uh have a nice
photo to share with you courtesy of
leonard otis
i believe this is the moment
this picture was captured carlson on
move before he plays his 31st move
appears confident caruana
um he is
locked in and yeah these two
are both
super resourceful and
resilient i mean uh their
last 19
classical games have all been drawn
so and it only ever takes one slip
and you can squander an advantage so
they are both uh locked in
to this game okay
play follows with c5
and uh the knight now goes in reverse so
this is where white is now really
starting to gain
something just in general right what has
just happened white moved forward
and generated a threat and black reacted
by
running in reverse rarely
is this good for the uh the player who's
running in reverse uh if you're if black
tries to move forward
um there are issues with that yeah
you're generating a threat but now
you have pins to get out of so
okay white keeps the pressure on
black's going backwards white's
regrouping
threatening now a fork
so that's sidestepped rook a6
95 check king e2
some shifty king moves here
is on f3 e2 d3 back to e2 what's the
point of going to e2 here
well it anticipates f6 the knight now
can fall back to a cozy square
he would remain in that sweet spot of
the board
key 16 squares and it also keeps open
the option to maybe
transfer rook to the d file and
potentially coordinate with the knight
on d7
i think many players in this position
may be really tempted to
say well i have that past pawn
on c5 and they say past pawns must be
pushed but
there's i believe a reason to not play
c6 straight away i mean for one it'll be
stopped cold with knight to c7
but i think the thing here is that when
you play c6 you
black no longer has to worry about maybe
a knight jump
into c6 that can be pretty dangerous for
sure
so that legal move is kept open to white
by not
simply pushing a past pawn
all right king e2 in this case
rook c2 safeguarding the king
a blend of repositioning preventative
moves anticipating what it is black
maybe trying to do to
influence white's position some some
offense and defense going on here
rook c8 rook b3
defense of the seventh rank for black
rook c4 tiny
tiny advan uh tiny tiny improvements
here
uh rook c5 knight d3
and e5 um
this is kind of a a lashing out
type move i believe right around this
stage carwana had
around 11 minutes
um yeah this is going to result
in the loss of a pawn e5 we're going to
have
knight takes e and then black gets the c
pawn
white gets active on the seventh rank
eventually white wins a pawn
so why does black go for a move such as
e5
is it out of frustration i don't believe
that's the case
i believe it has more to do with um
you know if i simply take a sit-and-wait
approach
a sit and wait approach i
that's that's rarely a good idea
white is able to make tiny improvements
still to his position
black has i believe basically exhausted
um you know if you look at the pieces
the knights and the rooks
what can they do that will
really you know what improvements are
there left for those pieces
can maybe move a pawn over here but
eventually what it's
what's going to happen is that this
material plus that white has
there are ways to improve we could see
it with maybe a4 rook b5
we could also see it in the form of f3
e4 that's maybe the clearest one
to see how white is making progress
what's happening with f3 and e4 if black
simply tries to sit and wait
the knight is driven back and
also a new square is produced for the
white king the king can start to improve
so
easy ways for white to improve not so
much for black
all right we have e5
exchanges on board rook versus knight
or excuse me a rook and knight vs rook
and knight
check on board king e6
uh if instead of king e6 if rook
f7 uh rook sees haven't excused me we
could have the rook exchange followed up
with knight c6
and white wins the a pawn a second pawn
and that would not just be any pawn
white would then have a an outside
uh an outside pass pawn a past rook pawn
and a past rook pawn is a nightmare to a
knight
it's really inconvenienced having go
having to go to the edge
to have to stop that passer okay
so there is no rook c7 also knight c7
you could take on a7
rook takes knight rick takes knight
white yet again
still up two pawns at the end of the day
what do we have king e6
knight takes on f7
rook a5 and the best move here
in the computer's eyes is knight takes
h6
is that a good decision
practically speaking no
uh to take on a on h6 and allow this
pawn to be captured
is completely unnecessary this would
not be showing i'd say clean
technique um why is that well
we're now now all of a sudden uh
entering what could very well turn out
to be a foot race
a time sensitive position what am i
talking about well at this point we have
these guys
as passers who's going to win the race
h4
uh a5 h5 a4
this is all completely unnecessary
it is completely appropriate at this
stage
to simply address the threat
that black has namely rook takes a3
defend consolidate regroup
and then slowly make progress with the
extra material you have
it is a four versus two majority for
white
a completely healthy four
versus unhealthy two
majority for white on the king side
okay technique
knight d8 check so that the rook
you know doesn't have to watch over the
night anymore
king d6 rook b3 simple defense
the last thing white needs to do is get
this clown that's on the edge
back in the ball game there was a threat
for
a fork threat here knight b7
so that's sidestepped rook f7 or knight
f7
now maybe that pawn will be picked up if
the king goes to e6
the knight's either gonna get h6 or
come back in the ball game back in the
ball game
perfectly central improve the king
and from here after knight to f4
that's the final move of the game black
resigns
white is ready to simplify the position
further
if knight takes knight you could take
with the pawn but the idea here
is to hit black with the check recapture
with the rook
and yeah you're up to two pawns
and that's just too much what else can
be tried
by black maybe black wants to
duck this knight exchange knight f6
and there's rook b4 check knight d3
check
and this is now count it a third pawn
for white so no good solution here
at this stage again caruana throws in
the towel
so um yeah these two
always interesting to see them go at it
we still have the candidates tournament
that was cut off midway
so we do not yet know who that
challenger will be for carlson it could
very well
turn out to be caruana um
we'll see when that time comes as usual
i will look forward to covering the
world chess championship match
um if we have a look at the tale the
tape on this one
see how accurate
these guys are here we go
um yeah a nice advantage
for carlson right around this point
after rook to c6 there was some jump
there
and it just grew from that point you
could still
you could see that even
even though caruana lost still
the the quality of play all right
average 70 pound loss for carlson 17 to
car one is 20
that's still very very high level um
i don't know it's it's to be expected
with these two
they're awesome world's best
top two anyhow
uh as usual feel free to
leave any feedback to this video in the
comments section below
i hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
you